I'm an idiot
it's showtime i don't deserve these powers if
i'm being honest like what am i even contributing
wow there's already a superhero with
a red suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so manly
and batman it's so cool and i'm just me
i feel like a fraud it doesn't matter um
anyway the wizard gave me superpowers and
then everybody got super powers was
everyone going to fight crime okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their own thing
and i'm the only one trying to keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician right
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like you
but i've seen all of the fast and the
furious movies lady it's all about family
family guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show his
i don't know how we fight powers like this
think i know how to fix
this dude but i really don't
everyone can be worthy let's give it a chance now
go fight for your family go fight for the world
i just threw a truck and a dragon i love my life
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
shazam 2 fury of the gods trailer video from
comic con there's a whole bunch of easter eggs so
we'll break it all down there's a bunch of comic
con trailers i'm still working through so be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos make sure you
enable alerts for my channel too it's probably
going to take a couple more days to get through
all the really big stuff seriously there were so
much cool stuff that they dropped at comic con
real quick shout out to my friends at raid shadow
legends who asked to sponsor this video raid
shadow legends is one of the biggest mobile games
in the world right now that's totally free to play
that's right it's free they wanted me to tell you
about the high elves one of my favorite factions
some cool history behind their race their homeland
arabia is thousands of years old surviving the
fall of the lizardmen empire they helped the
human form civilizations and defeated the orc
horde when it attacked the entire continent the
lord of darkness siroth convinced a bunch of them
to turn evil causing a civil war it nearly wiped
out their entire race but they rallied and rebuilt
even stronger than before lissandra is one of my
favorites she's one of the best champions in the
game but manipulating the turn meter meaning she
makes your champions get more opportunity to do
damage in battles and there's a ton of new stuff
happening in raid this month they're bringing
out five new champions they're overhauling the
champion vault and they've got a load of awesome
smaller updates as well on top of that raid's
running a huge series of summer splash events
for the whole month where you can get your hands
on some incredible skins for everyone's favorite
dwarf trunda brand new players can get a free
starter pack worth almost 30 dollars of free
champion aina and also this cool in-game loot all
that free stuff you can find in your inbox in the
upper right hand corner for the next 30 days
so be sure to check it out but the big thing
in this trailer is just teasing what's been going
on the last couple of years with the shazamly and
they actually called them the shazamly during the
comic-con panel even though that was more of a pop
culture fan thing the big ideas the movies meant
to pick up a couple years after the events of
the first film they've been activist heroes in
the philadelphia area the last couple of years
but the big joke that they open with is him in
therapy because he doesn't feel like he's as
good as say like the justice league heroes like is
he using his powers as effectively as he could be
there are a ton of easter eggs and references
to the other justice league movies and some of
the other justice league heroes as well as pop
culture references like fast and furious and
other funny stuff so we'll point those out as
we go through those parts of the trailer you
probably recognize pj burn from like a thousand
other things he's playing his pediatrician like
you realize i'm a pediatrician here i'm not an
actual therapist because the whole joke is that
billy is actually a little kid like he should
still be seeing a pediatrician but his doctor
here doesn't know that he's really billy batson
an actual kid in the body of an adult if you look
around the doctor's office here too there's a ton
of dc easter eggs probably the biggest wtf is the
green lantern easter egg in the background but
like there are a bunch of wonder woman plushies
there's an s for starro in the background here
referencing the events of the suicide squad movie
there's titano the super ape from the superman
comics that represents the letter t he was a chimp
named toto that was sent to space during a test
flight and was bombarded with cosmic rays that
gave him superpowers that superman fought way way
back in the classic comics there's several wonder
woman plushies there's batman plushies there's a
batman action figure there's a flash action figure
but like i said there's a green lantern action
figure meaning that green lantern already exists
in this continuity and this is meant to take place
in the dc eu like this is the new timeline like
the movie takes place around the same time is the
events of the black adam movie so that the shazam
lead doesn't get caught up in what's happening
during the black adam movie like they explain
why they don't rush over to conduct gal gadot's
wonder woman also has a cameo seen during the
movie when he's in the therapy session talking
to this pediatrician as if he is a therapist
he's talking about a dream that he had we're in
the dream he was dating wonder woman so it's kind
of like a funny work around kind of cameo scene
but if you remember at the end of the first movie
they explained that after that small time jump he
had met the justice league because henry cavill's
superman comes to eat lunch with them so he's
already met all these justice league characters
so he actually knows wonder woman you also notice
there's an easter egg for the annabelle doll from
the director's horror movie the annabelle movies
like he comes from an indie horror background
that's how he came to the shazam franchise you
notice when he's flying through the city talking
about how he's been a lousy superhero the past
couple of years they'll show you different footage
of freddie freeman complaining about being hurt by
something and he's wearing another big easter egg
reference t-shirt it's a batman and robin t-shirt
but this time it's an actual bat dressed as batman
in an actual robin bird dressed as robin if you
remember in the last film he was the person that
was wearing the henry cavill logo superman t-shirt
during the panel people asked zachary levi about
crossing over with henry cavill superman or if
he'd have another cameo scene during the movie and
he had all these funny responses trying to waffle
and not actually answer because he's under nda
right now like he can't actually tell people oh
he's in the movie or he's not in the movie i can
neither confirm nor deny allegations such as these
these are not questions you're allowed to ask me
on this stage right now reportedly we're going
to get another henry cavill cameo scene at least
during the black adam movie i don't know if we're
supposed to get one during the shazam 2. they said
that they were supposed to do it a while ago but i
don't know if they've changed those plans and when
he falls out of the sky eating it all over the
pavement in the background you can actually see
a fulchi libs reference that's actually a
reference to an italian horror filmmaker
that the director is just a huge fan of because
he himself is a horror movie director by trade
as you notice all the shazamly got costume
upgrades because their powers generate their
costumes they can actually change their costumes
to look like whatever they want to any time they
activate their powers the other big difference
now is that the young actress for mary marvel is
now also playing the powered up version of mary
marvel just because all the kids are aging up
so fast like they're so much bigger than they were
in the first movie and she's just at the right age
to play the powered up version so it just makes
sense you notice billy batson is also wearing a
goonies t-shirt just because that kind of that
vibe of the team during the movie they're kind
of like the goonies going on adventures together
the big structure that you see here is where the
god level characters live the villains in the
movie they haven't completely explained how this
version of the wizard shazam is back because he
seemingly died like he seemingly vaporized into
nothingness when he gave all of his powers to
billy but however they've explained it they've
trapped him the three villains are meant to be
three daughters of the greek titan atlas who they
draw their stamina from based on this acronym here
helen mirren's character is named hespera she's
the oldest sister she's named after the hesperides
who were the daughters of the evening the nymphs
of the west and they were the three daughters of
the titan atlas this was a bit of a change on the
name but it's a riff on the idea that there are
three daughters of the titan atlas and each of
them have different names but they are the three
daughters of that titan lucy lou is playing the
middle daughter named calypso and they've changed
the backstory for the rachel ziegler character
she's playing someone called anthea in the movie
i believe that she's also supposed to be one
of these three daughters of the titan atlas but
in the movie they make it kind of seem like she
winds up honey potting freddy freeman like they're
trying to get the powers of the shazamly back so
they try to take the staff of the wizard back that
he broke at the end of the first movie whatever
they do with that they wind up reforming that
but i think the idea is that the rachel zigler
character rebels against her sisters and winds up
helping the family like she actually does fall in
love with freddy freeman like they do have some
kind of relationship going on in the background
but you can see her in her god tier form here like
with all of her armor and her using her powers
in greek mythology anthea was meant to be
the daughter of zeus in another character
i think they just changed that and made
her the daughter of the greek titan atlas
because this trades so heavily on greek mythology
the greek titans and obviously wonder woman's gods
are the greek gods i'm sure there'll be some
references to that as well because you also
see some of the greek ruins during the trailer
it seems like what they plan to do is restore
the earth to a state when the titans ruled like
whatever they're doing unleashing all this power
you see all this greenery growing all over the
philadelphia area something they're doing is
physically changing the world back to this old
school state when the titans ruled they make
the obvious vin diesel family fast and furious
joke because he's expecting the shazami to show
up the minute that he pounds his fist and says
family but also the other joke here is that helen
mirren is in the fast and furious movies i love
the ways that she reacts to that too like what
it looks like their parents wind up finding out
that they do have all these powers like you see
them standing there on the rooftop with the wizard
shazam also this version of the wizard seems like
a much younger version of the character so the way
they explain him coming back sounds pretty twisty
this scene is inside the rock of eternity
where their new lair is where the chamber
of all the thrones are like she's sitting in front
of the thrones looking at all these history books
trying to find information about the origin of
their powers in the origin of the gods they get
their powers from in the background you can see
that they basically turn their lair into their
own version of a bat cave like you see all these
lights hung up it's basically like a little kid's
idea of what a bat cave should look like this is
just another scene in a different part of the rock
of eternity where it seems like they go to find
more information about the villains the idea is
that the rock of eternity exists kind of like
a doctor who tardis style situation where it's
bigger on the inside there's just more and more
rooms it just goes on forever it's also a gateway
to a bunch of different dimensions as well which
is why in the first movie you see them opening
doors to different dimensions it looks pretty
solid you can tell they spent way more money on
the visual effects budget the plot of the movie
seems pretty simple though like the daughters
of the gods that they get their powers from
want to take those powers back but they're also
introducing the black atom character so they want
to hop up a shazam versus black adam movie at some
point in the future even though he's not meant to
be a big part of this film i think it will just
be like a post-credits scene just teasing that
they figure out that there's like another dude
out there who has the same powers that they do
i'll do a new video for the black adam comic-con
trailer in the next couple of days so make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel for that
but the way the rock explained it is that when he
comes out of his prison after five thousand plus
years he doesn't know that the shazamly exists he
doesn't know the justice league exists he doesn't
know anything about superman all of his current
knowledge stops at about 5000 years ago the minute
he went into that prison so it'll probably be the
end of the black adam movie before he also learns
about the shazamily about the justice league
characters either way post all your reactions
and all your theories in the comments below if
there's any big easter eggs that you spotted in
the trailer that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments but we'll
get more trailers later this year around the time
black adam comes out because this is coming out in
december we don't have to wait that long after
the black adam movie to get the shazam 2 movie
there's a bunch of other trailers like i said
i'll try to do videos for all them in the next
couple of days everyone click here for my brand
new black panther wakanda forever trailer video
in easter eggs and clicking for my brand new
she-hulk trailer in daredevil easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!